how'd you do there Flyers game it's 20
stories your doorman's intimidating tell
us a little bit about yourself Parker
not much to tell really Peter this is
aunt and uncle did you catch that spider
guy yet no but we will
this guy wears a mask like an outlaw I
think he's trying to do something maybe
the police can't hint you know if you're
gonna steal cars don't dress like a car
thief you a cop
you seriously think I'm a cop and the
skin tie red and blue suit who are you
I know it's been rough for you Peter
I forgot all about that thing he was
your dad's your father was a very
secretive man Peter dr. Connors I'm
Richard Parker's son your father and I
were gonna change the lives of millions
including mine
extraordinary how did you come up with
this
as a rumor of a new species in New York
we can be aggressive if threatened
I kind of stopped him because I created
him
your job maybe this
thirty-eight of New York's finest versus
one guy in a unitard Wow
if you want the truth Peter
come & get it
I am issuing an arrest warrant
or the masked vigilante known as
spider-man
you